[Music]
all right so the dilemma
man started with
i need help
none of this love the pod big fan
yeah long time listener first time
caller none of that i need help all
right say less all right so so i've been
married to this girl for three years
this was all great until
she got pregnant and her lust died out
okay
it died out okay we're talking sex every
day to nothing at all
so i decide
i don't know what this guy's on but i
love his honesty yeah so i decided to
find a girl in brackets without my wife
knowing that i could smash until the
baby came out wow
he said that with chess wow
i decided to find a girl that i could
smash until the baby came out wow
amazing and it worked fine
[Laughter]
yeah
ah and it worked fine and i told the
girl basically i have a wife and this
isn't a long time thing
and she was on board
she has no problem with it
now to the problem
now to the problem yeah the baby's here
and i don't need sighting anymore
i tried ending it
this [ __ ] went off
[Music]
she started threatening me that she
would tell my wife about us and how she
would [ __ ] up my new baby's future
what should i do
wow
if my wife found out she would leave me
instantly
and it was gonna [ __ ] up my little
family should i hire a contract killer
should i tell my wife should i call her
bluff i don't know what to do
oh he's in a pickle he's in a
pick-a-lickle wow he's in a pic is that
it that's this yeah he's in a pickle
ah
so recap
homeboy is married for three years he's
in a lovely relationship him and his
wife just want to bang
she gets pregnant her desire just
just dies out which is normal and he
needs a little something to get just get
him through until the u arrives so he
finds something tells her
look this is my situation i'm just
trying to nut are you down she says i'm
down cool does this thing baby arrives
tries to lock her up and she says nah
she says nah
i'm spilling all the beans
what do you do i think
ah not necessarily he can't necessarily
call her bluff
but
he obviously can't [ __ ] hire a
contractor he has to play he has to play
it by ear like
oh
um
what does he do
there
fam what does he actually do
because the problem's not going to go
away yeah
you know
you might have to set her up a little
standing order yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cool
a little paypal transactions
or unless you just keep piping her
forever
until she gets cancer or something i
don't know keep piping of course these
are short-term loans whatever you want
to call it he's all short-term bro bro
wow
that is very sticky
that's very sticky
oh hard dicks make you do dumb things
sometimes terrible things [ __ ]
he's locked he's going he's like he's
locked down there's no way out right let
me think about this logically [ __ ] how
does he get out of this situation and
that okay
as a premise this is not us condoning
his behavior this really is not asking
we're just discussing
he's done the dirty work and he needs
help so we can't judge him at this point
it's too late he's way too late yeah
he's he's done what he's done and he
just needs our help yeah homeboy's
easiness
dirky one
um right realistically okay if it was me
what would i do in this situation right
i need my wife at home i'm not losing
that your wife i'm not a newborn no wife
a newbo i'm not losing that
but this hoe on the side she's saying
keep banging me or i'm telling everyone
everything you're not locking me off but
it's also one of them ones where she's
you're going to keep banging her she's
eventually still going to tell someone
true she will of course she will and if
you pay her she's always the thing is i
can never pay her yeah i'm not because
if you pay her she's probably going to
say keep paying me i'm going to tell her
yeah
it's
the rent's double now that's it
plus having a new kid nah man his
finances regardless of your finances
it's a it's a pistic right i'm trying to
figure out what is the better option
because he's he's literally got two
options tell your missus the truth or
call her bluff
those are his two [ __ ] options
that's literally it there are no other
options in my opinion i was thinking he
just needs to pack his share move
oh this whole family let's relocate we
got a newborn let's start a new life
that's easier said than i know but the
panic state in me that's what i'll
suggest oh but i'm assuming the way uh
the way i see it is that's not even an
option because this is 2022. i doubt he
would i doubt this who knows where he
lives
she's on a she's coming to her as a
woman on an instagram team
this relocating ain't gonna solve no
issues it's always an away game for him
so he's always getting to herself yeah
yeah yeah okay so i don't think she's
threatening to come to his yard
i think she's looking to drop a local dm
tape yeah i'm coming to you as a woman
okay so so you can't run away from that
you can't run away from it yeah so i'm
saying he's got two options tell your
mrs the truth and see what you can
pattern
or
call her bluff
and let's take it from there take it
from there the only issue with the call
in the bluff is that obviously
if you go to your wife with your heart
in your hand
and just be like
i [ __ ] up there is a small chance you
might there is a small chance there is
don't do that that's not fair there's a
small chance he can make it out
small
because you're a cheat sheet
but that's what i'm saying let's before
we before we conclude your um your
synopsis or however you want to call it
let's flip the scripts right okay
you say there's a small chance we we
know there's no chance
because
if the roles were reversed yeah and
let's say for example it's one of them
ones where
you're in a relationship or i'm in a
relationship and she's gone through my
phone
the trust is broken
i'm never going to view this
relationship the same regardless of what
you say and how you wanna
it's it's you [ __ ] up you have [ __ ]
up regardless of where you say okay i
forgive you we're gonna start again
you're always gonna second guess if i've
left my phone somewhere
she's probably gonna go through it
because she's done it before she's got
the means to do it again
so the hope and the chance you can you
can say sing that to the cows come home
you can sing that to the cows coming
brother she's not gonna forgive you
uh
okay whilst she was pregnant oh i know
your first you together yeah i know
marital home but that's what there's no
chance that's his justification i know
it's also the worst thing you can do but
it's not like he just decided to cheat
while she's pregnant he was cheating
because she was pregnant
he just needed a hole
because she was pregnant yeah
um
but yeah he's
he's ruining it
that you're probably right there is no
way out there's no way out there um call
her a [ __ ] bluff then to be fair
that's the only option
because if she's i'm gonna ruin your
future baby's life just repeat what
she's saying to you and be like ra
so that's what you want to do you want
to ruin my family's life because you're
upset why why do you okay you need to
interview this girl yeah you need to to
reflect her own craziness back at her
and be like look i understand you're
upset i understand you're upset but you
knew what the situation was told you
from the jump and if our lives were
different maybe we could have been a
real something
but our lives aren't different i've made
a commitment to my family and i really
sincerely hope you can appreciate that i
really [ __ ] do
from the sounds i know you're upset i
know you're angry and it sounds like you
don't appreciate that yeah you're a good
girl with morals you're a good woman
you're a good woman background with a
great upbringing and a great background
of the dream yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have
immovable morals yeah and that's what
attracted to me you were in the first
place come on come on this is what i was
here for in the first place you're an
amazing woman and like i said if i
wasn't already married and i didn't have
this kid it would be you times will be
different but i can't change the past
and my kid can't grow without a father
just because i really want to be of you
because i do actually want to be with
you
i do actually want to be with you
but
i can't circumcise you because i'm a
good man and i need to be there for my
son yeah i really hope you understand
that
and if not and if you want to ruin
everything you have every right because
i'm a human being and i've made mistakes
in my life and if if you you're you've
got the you you've got all the cards
yeah if you think i deserve to be
punished for the mistakes i've made by
falling for you
falling falling for you then hey
i'll have to accept that fate
but
if you can see it in your heart to
understand where i'm coming from and why
i need to stick by my commitments then
i'd really appreciate support and i hope
we can remain friends moving forward
from here because i do appreciate it as
a person
and the tom tom
snatch that snatch juicy
that's when you give her a little
smack on everyone that scene i'm gonna
miss that
i'm gonna miss that i think that's the
best answer that's the best answer
you've given up for a fight request
period period you lied through your
teeth and it made sense
if i was there yet i'm thinking
[Applause]
that's the only choice you've got damn
that's tough i think the only choice
you've got there's no other way because
like i said if you
if you tell your missus and be like i'm
coming to you as a no i'm coming to you
as a man i'm going to poor my cousin
said we tell the truth your life is done
your family everything's done it's true
because it sounds like a very moral
thing to do until you say look
here's what it is you got pregnant and
we we weren't having any sex and i in my
head i was just like i thought maybe i
could just find a sighting as soon as
you start talking out loud you're like
what am i doing what am i saying what am
i actually saying hell
what have i done fam yeah oh that's
crazy it's crazy but yeah i feel like
that's the best possible yeah good
luck brother that's all i can say good
luck that is rather dicky situation
that's one of the stickiest situations
i've ever heard on this podcast
[Music]